a que conjuntos de números pertenece
3.40 28 pero con este 28 con esta línea
aquí arriba entonces lo primero que
tenemos que hacer antes de tratar de
contestar esta pregunta es recordar qué
significa esta línea de aquí arriba del
28 ok
esta línea lo que significa es que a la
derecha de este decimal se repite el 28
una infinidad de veces aquí este número
en realidad lo podemos escribir como
3.40 28 pero ahora tenemos que repetir
el 28
muchas veces ok es este número de aquí
nada más que digamos que sigo
escribiendo 28 una infinidad de veces
aquí a la derecha claro que como es
imposible que yo haga eso siempre es
muchísimo más fácil escribir simplemente
3.40 y luego el 28 con esta línea de
aquí arriba bueno ahora sí vamos a
preguntarnos aquí
juntos de números pertenece este número
así es que a ver el conjunto más grande
con el que podamos estar familiarizados
es el conjunto de los números reales
cierto conjunto de los números reales y
bueno por si no te acuerdas cuáles los
números reales de hecho los podemos
representar con la recta numérica
ok los números reales son todos los
puntitos que hay en la recta hacia el
infinito y hacia el menos infinito y
este número de aquí pues resulta ser un
punto de esta recta a ver podemos poner
por aquí el menos 1 al 0 al 1 al 2 al 3
4 y entonces este número de aquí está a
la derecha del 3 más o menos por aquí es
más grande que 3.4 porque tiene todos
estos decimales a la derecha pero es más
chico que 3.41 entonces definitivamente
es más chico que 3.5 así es que este es
un muy buen punto para representarlo
ahora aquí mismo podemos ver que este
número definitivamente no es un número
entero ni es un número natural pero si
es un número real ahora lo que no queda
tan claro es si este número es un número
racional o no no quería ver cuando son
los números racionales saber un número
que es racional
nacional
si y sólo si éste es mi símbolo de si y
sólo si se puede escribir como una
expresión racional de dos enteros aunque
ya esto es tal cual como decir que se
puede escribir como una fracción un
casey p se puede escribir como un número
entero entre otro número entero
m y n enteros en ceros entonces la
pregunta de si este número es un número
racional o no es equivalente a
preguntarnos si este número se puede
escribir como una fracción y eso es
justo lo que vamos a tratar de averiguar
me conozco por ahí un truco que está
buenísimo entonces tenemos por aquí x
igual a 3.40 28 infinitamente repetido
lo que estamos diciendo que x es igual
al número que nos interesa tanto y ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar x
por 10 mil 10.000 xy pensar en cuánto
vale eso porque estoy multiplicando a x
por 10.000 pues porque lo que quiero
hacer es recorrer este punto decimal
para que nos quede por acá ok y la forma
de hacer eso es multiplicar por 10.000
porque cada que multiplicamos por 10
estamos recorriendo el punto decimal un
lugar hacia la derecha
y 10.000 es 10 a la 4 así es que vamos a
recorrer punto decimal 1 2 3 4 entonces
10.000 por equis es 3 4 028 el punto nos
quedó por aquí y ahora hay que recordar
que a la derecha de este 28 hay una
infinidad de 28 por lo tanto a la
derecha de este punto decimal hay
todavía otra infinidad de 28 y ahora
tiene una parte muy importante del truco
ok ahora vamos a multiplicar a equis
pero lo grande por 10.000 por cien y
entonces este punto decimal se va a
mover dos lugares a la derecha y lo que
nos queda es 340 punto 28 repetido
muchas veces ahora porque nos interesan
estos números pues porque si restamos
este número menos este número
estos decimales infinitos con una
infinidad de cifras
exactamente iguales y a la hora de
restar los se eliminan y entonces nada
más nos quedan puras cosas enteras
finitas con una cantidad más accesible
para nosotros de cifras ok si restamos
10.000 x menos 100 x que por cierto las
dos cosas son múltiplos de equis y eso
nos va a ayudar bastante van a ver como
más adelante nos va a quedar igual a 34
mil 28 menos 340 aunque porque el punto
28 repetido infinitas veces menos punto
28 repetido infinitas veces nos queda 0
pero bueno vamos a escribirlo paso por
paso
pero antes de empezar a hacer las
cuentas déjame ordenó esto un poco más
para que los puntos decimales estén en
el mismo lugar
y ahora si punto 28 28 28 28 y así hasta
la infinidad menos lo mismo punto 28 28
28 28 y así hasta la infinidad o sea
este menos este como son exactamente
iguales nos queda 0 ahora por acá 8 - 08
porque dos menos cuatro pues le vamos a
tener que pedir prestado al vecino que
le va a tener que pedir prestado al
vecino aquí este 4 le presta uno
entonces nos queda 3 en este lugar pero
aquí entonces nos queda 10 claro que
queremos que éste le preste 1 por acá
entonces
aquí nos va a quedar un 9 porque le
presta 1 a éste para que nos quede 12
bien entonces 12 menos cuatro son 8 otra
vez y 9 menos tres son
y finalmente aquí tenemos un 3
3 y de este lado lo que tenemos es
10.000 x menos 100 x eso lo que nos
queda es haber 10.000 menos 100 pues eso
es 9 mil 900
x y bueno este punto cero lo podemos
borrar bueno ya ahora ya que tenemos
esto así vamos a encontrar a x con
usando esta fórmula aunque entonces lo
que tenemos que hacer es despejar x y
para hacer eso dividimos entre 9.900 de
los dos lados del igual
nueve mil novecientos entre 9.900 es un
1 así es que de aquí nos queda
simplemente una equis y de este lado
pues nos queda 3 3 688 entre 9 900 y
listo aquí tenemos algo muy interesante
ahora que hay porque osea recuerden
quién es x x es este número de aquí que
es este número del cual nos estábamos
preguntando qué conjuntos pertenece acá
y entonces tomamos este número hicimos
muchas manipulaciones algebraicas y lo
logramos escribir como un entero entre
otro entero y ese es justo la definición
de ser un número racional aunque hay
entonces con todo esto que acabamos de
hacer aquí acabamos de demostrar que x o
sea nuestro número 3.40 y 28-28 28 y el
28 repitiéndose una infinidad de veces
es un número racional racional
y bueno es cierto esta fracción se puede
simplificar mucho se puede dividir entre
dos y seguramente también se puede
dividir entre cuatro sin embargo esto no
nos importa lo único que nos importa es
que se puede escribir como una fracción
y bueno este truco de recorrer el punto
decimal un lugar a la derecha de las
cifras que se repiten y restarle ese
mismo número pero recorriendo el decimal
justo antes de que empiecen las cifras
que se repiten es un truco que se puede
aplicar para cualquier número que tenga
este tipo de decimales aunque estos
decimales que se repiten una infinidad
de veces ahora no todos los números que
tienen una infinidad de decimales son
racionales hay números que tienen
decimales que no siguen ningún tipo de
patrón y que no los puedes escribir como
muchas cifras y después una secuencia de
decimales que se repiten y se repiten
y tan infinitamente y justo esos números
que no tienen una secuencia que se
repite y se repite y se repite
son los números irracionales que hay
números como el número pi que
seguramente has escuchado algo de ese
número entonces este número no es un
número irracional y ya habíamos visto
que no era ni un número natural ni un
número entero